Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast.
Sorry for the fucking March 2nd I got to tell you something.
Oh,
I'm coming out of the gate this week people.
I just fucking,
I just did like eight minutes.
A great fucking eight minutes.
A great fucking riff.
The whole God damn thing.
And then I looked down in the fucking God damn stupid ass fucking thing isn't
even on.
You know why this is the exact same fucking device I had the Olympus ls 10 now
it's the Olympus 14 and wouldn't you fucking know they couldn't just leave well
enough alone.
They got to add like 20 fucking steps and some stupid broads fucking voice in
there telling me what I know I'm doing.
So I fucking riff for like eight fucking minutes and I find out the thing is
even fucking recording.
I fucking,
I hate technology.
Okay.
I absolutely,
if I don't understand,
why do we keep going forward?
All right,
we got enough shit.
This is as comfortable as it's going to fucking get one.
Can we just have the shit and this is how it fucking works.
And when you figure something out that's,
you know how it fucking works.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I told you guys and I fucking will never stop bitching about these things.
I fucking,
uh,
was talking on my podcast saying how,
you know,
I needed a new pair of fucking headphones one week,
right?
So,
uh,
some fucking personal listens to the podcast.
Ended up sending me a pair of fucking wireless fucking headphones,
wireless fucking headphones.
And I gotta tell you I've never had no fucking problems with something in my
life.
You fucking sitting there my whole life headphones fucking work.
You plug them into something that's charged the headphones.
Now the amount of fucking times I sat there with my phone listening to fucking
music,
my phone is charged and then the headphones went out and I couldn't listen.
It's just fucking,
why did you add that step?
Electronic Pencil sharpeners and all that shit.
And now it's just something that's going to fucking,
that drives me up.
The other one,
the other pencil sharpener.
You could buy a pencil sharpener once and you'll,
you're gonna have to think of 100 fucking years and little kids could walk up
your eyes with yesterday.
She was my grandfather's,
well he used to,
you know,
fucking sharpened pencils and then,
and when he built stuff,
when we still had good warden,
this country,
right.
It wasn't all wet because it was brand new fucking trees.
It was old shit.
Oh my God,
I was in such a great fucking mood.
It's completely changed the whole fucking vibe of this God damn thing.
Anyways,
let me relax.
Calm down.
Let me try to get back to where I was.
I was in such a fucking great mood cause I'm back out here in Los [inaudible]
Congolese.
We make sure this thing's recording.
Let me make sure everything's okay.
And the Goddamn nerve center here,
you know,
fuck.
Anyways,
I'm back out here in la.
It's so fucking awesome cause I was just in New York City,
right?
I uh,
I flew back there and I did night at too many fucking,
and I gotta tell you that show lives up to its name.
I was standing backstage in the green room and I couldn't believe how many
people fucking came back there.
Jon Bon Jovi,
Steve Will Shemi,
Chris Rock,
Louis C,
K on and on and on and on and on.
Okay.
I think one of the guys with the long hair,
I think he might've been the keyboard player for Bon Jovi.
I don't know who the fuck he was was amazing.
Right?
I have my autograph book out.
No Kid.
Anyways,
uh,
will forte.
I got to uh,
got to talk to him and uh,
you know that guys,
one of my favorites.
And last night I actually watched his,
uh,
his new show last man on earth and it's so fucking funny.
It's just a Goddamn it,
I said such nice things on at the last fucking time,
you know,
now I'm just trying to remember what the fuck I said because of this stupid ass
fucking record.
And let me just fucking just speak from the heart here.
Like that guy is so fucking original.
Any,
he commits so hard to everything.
He does have such a fucking huge fan of his.
And,
uh,
I talked to him briefly backstage.
I'm going to try to get him on the podcast.
I just want to find out how the fuck he got something this original on a major
network.
They usually freak the fuck out.
Like they always say they want to do something new.
You know,
they always say they want to do something new,
but in the end,
you know,
they fucking cut it down and everybody gives him shit.
But I get it.
I get it.
You know what I mean?
Everybody's brave with somebody else's fucking money.
But when it's your money and your job on the line,
you're going to go with what has worked in the past.
I'm sorry,
my voice is still cracking so I get what the fuck they do.
You know what I mean?
I got the,
I got this whole new bit that I'm going to be doing about fatties and fucking
ugly people who are bitch,
Moan and complain that beautiful people are in movies.
It's like,
yeah,
you know what?
Why don't you go put your fucking million dollars up and go put some troll up
there.
Let me give me a fucking break.
It's what it is.
Do you think I sit here wondering why is a balding redheaded male?
I'm not a fucking love interest in a movie.
I don't.
I get it.
You know why?
Because of WHO's my fucking zillion dollars,
I wouldn't cast me either.
Everybody fucking bitch moaning and complaining.
Get on a treadmill and shut the fuck up.
All right.
We're all out there eating salad.
You think we want to do it?
We don't.
It's part of the fucking business.
You know?
Why don't they just slow down the fucking NBA and glow or the rim so he can play
in that toe.
Fucking unreal.
Anyways,
let me plow ahead here.
Oh,
that's going to be a fun chunk of material I got.
I got,
oh Jesus Christ.
I got to vent on that one tonight.
I'm going up.
I'm fucking talking about that.
I can't wait to see that.
That's me rubbing my hands together with the microphone on my head.
Anyways,
the last man on earth is a is absolutely,
uh,
you know,
you don't want you to searching for a new show.
I still been searching ever since.
Breaking bad went off the year,
you know what I mean?
Just trying to,
you know,
I saw the killing killing was great and I blew through that cause it's fucking
Netflix,
right?
They've got all of them.
They turn you into a junkie,
right?
Instead of just giving you a little bit a week,
can you keep your habit and in control like the networks,
fucking Netflix.
You just sit there,
you know,
you'll lose a Wiki your life.
Um,
so anyways,
I gotta watch this and then I got,
I got to get caught up on better call Saul because I was overseas when it came
out.
And uh,
I'm really bad with,
with,
you know,
looking shit up on the Internet and trying to find out where to watch it.
I want to watch it legally.
Um,
if anybody knows where I can watch like the first two episodes,
because I'm now taping the series,
I'm really excited.
But,
uh,
I'm going to do one little spoiler thing on last man on earth.
All right.
It's going to go down here and about to fucking,
well,
I'll do the,
it's going down right now.
All right.
So it's fucking stick your fingers in your,
I'm going to time this out perfectly.
10 seconds.
I'm going to say it all right.
In three,
two,
one Kristen Schaal is also on it.
She absolutely fucking kills it and blew me away with their acting and I'm just
so fucking site.
Whenever I see a standup comic or Comedians in general showing this industry
that we are actually can really be good actors,
they fucking kill it.
I absolutely love the show.
Please watch it.
All right,
done.
Okay.
Anyways,
I'm plowing ahead here.
Uh,
so all right,
I'm over the technology thing.
I'm actually in such a fucking great movie after it being back in New York,
uh,
which I loved,
you know,
taking the subway and shit.
I miss doing that stuff and seeing,
you know,
fucking neurotic people and crazy people and uh,
I dunno,
you know what I miss most about living in la?
This is going to be weird.
You know what?
I missed Puerto Ricans,
you know what I mean?
They just don't have any Puerto Rican self here.
I don't know what it is.
Not that there's anything wrong with Mexican people,
but you know,
La could use some Puerto Rican if fucking women are gorgeous.
I was on the subway or in a restaurant was like God damn,
look at her.
And I was like,
that's right.
Puerto Rican women.
That's what's been missing from my day to day plus New York.
You know what I mean?
Not everybody's not hiding in cars.
You know,
they're fucking on the subways and shit walking down the street.
A bunch of cutie pies.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
so,
but you know what I do love about living out here.
I love when it's like the level that has been studied.
It's been snowing back on the east coast to just drop into that and actually be
excited to see snow.
You know,
skipping down the street,
wanting to make a snowman and shit and everybody else has totally miserable.
There's nothing more fun.
And everybody back east.
You probably at this point,
if you're,
you know,
over the age of 22 or 23 you have that douchebag,
east coast friend that moved to southern California or someplace warm and you
know what we do,
right?
You know we do.
We just wait for a couple to,
we,
we time it right?
Not during the holidays,
during the holidays were on radio silence cause that's when we were missing the
winner.
Right?
All the fucking went,
all the fucking Christmas songs are all about snow right here.
Sleigh bells ringing.
Link.
Thank.
Thank tingling to it's fucking snowing and ba Ba ba Ba ba right.
Giddyup Giddyup Giddyup let's go.
Let's look at us though.
Told you I was in a good mood.
The wonderland ups know a fuck.
What the fuck?
You know I'm going to have native Americans relate to that fucking Christmas
music,
right?
Is White people are in the and Giddyup Giddyup Giddyup let's go.
You used to live here,
then we can emit it.
Fucking Jana side yellow.
Now we have a fuck house where you use to fucking laid,
bup,
Oberlo you know,
the nerve of us to write such happy songs on the same land that that fucking
horror happened.
Oh,
you know,
Dasher and dancer and Prancer and Vixen,
the Cherokee,
those sue,
the cro and Apache.
Where did they go?
Go.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so you know the deal.
So we love to fucking call up in January and February.
The best time to do it is right at the end of January when these poor cons back
east,
now they've got another month that they shit,
right?
It's just desolate,
You've already the high of a New Year,
you've already fucked up your New Year's resolutions and you just coming out
right with the,
a fucking ice scraper
every fucking goddamn morning.
Then that's when we call acting like we don't know what we're doing.
What's going on?
Don't know why.
Yeah,
yeah.
About them.
Bruin says starting to finally fucking play,
you know,
a seed or whatever.
What I,
they got to rebuild kit.
So,
uh,
you know,
what's going on.
But back then,
right?
You do the whole fucking thing.
Oh Geez.
Bloggers,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And then that's when he get to hit.
Ah,
Oh,
what out here?
Yeah.
I don't,
you know,
I haven't looked.
I think it feels like about like 68 degrees.
Yeah.
I'm standing out here wearing a hoodie and Pajama bottoms,
taking my dog for a walk.
Probably going to go on a hike a little bit later,
get a breakfast burrito.
I fucking love it.
I absolutely love it.
And then when I got to go back,
you know,
you visit winner,
it visited for a few days,
you know,
you fucking,
get yourself a hot chocolate,
you go skating or whatever.
You do your little fucking thing.
I love watching people back east,
dig it up,
dig it out there,
fucking cars,
you know,
and just talk every fucking year just talking about how sick of this,
the snow,
you know,
and I always want the person on the other side of the microphone would be like,
yeah,
but it's winter.
Yeah.
People just do it.
And then the summertime,
oh my God,
it's fucking he way.
But yes,
so sour.
It's sour.
You understand
there's too many fucking people.
We've put too much fucked up shit in the air and you were going to have crazy
weather.
It's going to be crazy cold and it's going to be crazy.
Fucking hot.
Okay.
What would you rather do?
Like I was thinking the other day,
would you rather have global warming or to have it go back to the Ice Age?
You know,
would you rather have the fucking the water and I'm not saying whether we're
creating it a,
not all the,
you know,
I think that without a doubt you can't have 7 billion people not having an
effect on the planet.
I know we are.
I went to Asia,
I saw it,
I breathe it in.
I held that tobacco with my fingers.
I just sounded like fucking Al Gore man.
When he ran for office and he was trying to talk to people down to Carolina,
going like,
ah,
I till the land,
I held that the grass,
some fingers sitting there.
Why the fuck would you ever say that we were in a suit and wingtips but you're
dirty people staring at you.
Like what the fuck is this guy talking about?
Huh?
What's he have a garden in the backyard of his fucking villa?
Um,
no,
I just saw what
the direction we were.
Fortunately,
the population over here is,
uh,
we're keeping it at bay,
but just the amount of shit that we buy.
I think a,
we create more waste or whatever,
but I will tell you this dude,
like the air quality over there was devastating.
Fucking devastating.
Like I felt like I was smoking five packs a day.
Like I had this scratchiness in my throat when I was in Hong Kong and it got
even worse in India.
And I'm not shitting on either country and I'm not shitting on the people there
because I love both countries and the people were awesome.
But you know,
you got to admit the fucking air quality is a,
it's horrific.
And right there that's,
that is too many people having an effect on the,
yeah,
it happens.
There's too many at one fucking thing.
That's why you know,
these,
these goddamn diseases,
all of this shit that we think of fucking evil and all of that,
the a bolas and size,
all of that shit is,
is it's there for a reason.
So what's the great thing about nature is it's all there.
It all serves a fucking purpose.
And the purpose of that shit is to keep us in line.
You know what I mean?
That's what it is.
But the fatal flaw is,
uh,
in nature is us,
it's us.
We're too fucking smart for our own good.
So rather than fucking,
you know,
a bunch of us dying off,
like what happens to every fucking God damn animal?
Something happens if a disease doesn't run through that,
that species of forest fire gets him.
You know,
we came up with medicine and all of this shit and there's a bunch of people,
like I told you,
I should not be here right now.
I should've died of an apparent in a ruptured appendix when I was in the sixth
grade.
All right.
But they got modern medicine and here I am just taking up space,
right?
I try.
I get a Prius,
I recycle the water bottles,
but you know,
they just throw them in the ocean.
I'm just another con that shouldn't be here walking around taking his shit that
ends up in a lake.
Right.
I didn't know where the fuck I'm going with this shit.
But,
um,
the fuck I totally lost my train.
I said,
I'm so fucking stupid.
I shouldn't even be like if I,
if I actually had to live off the Goddamn land,
I would be walking through the woods tracking something to halfway through it.
I would get distracted,
forget what I was hunting and I would starve to death.
Right.
Isn't that how it works?
I don't know how it works.
But anyways,
um,
I love it.
I love that it's fucking snowing back then.
There's all kinds of shit going on.
I didn't like that.
Uh,
that ice rink back in Massachusetts collapsed.
Thank God there was no kids out there skating or anything like that.
Um,
you know,
Jesus Christ,
that would have been fucking brutal.
But there's all this shit going on back then.
I don't,
I don't understand how this works,
but there's been so much snow that I guess they have in this problem.
My heart goes out to everybody back there cause I've had water damage in my
house and it is a fucking nightmare is a fucking nightmare.
But basically there's so much snow up on the roofs and then it starts to melt
during the day and then at night it freezes.
So then what happens is during the day when it starts to melt again,
for some reason I guess it melts down at the surface,
which makes no sense.
I figured that'd be the coldest or whatever.
The snow at the top trickles down.
Somehow it gets underneath this better ice and then there's no,
it can't run off the roof and it's so eventually just gets absorbed into the
roof and starts leaking down.
So they're doing this thing with,
it's starting to clear off the roots and roots and they put these salts socks up
there.
They never had that shit when I was a kid.
I never heard of that.
I guess you'd take a tube sock,
you fill it up with some of that rock salt and then you just lay it down on the
roof and somehow,
I don't know.
I love that.
I don't even,
I don't get out.
I don't get out of fucking works,
but there's a bunch of cons back then because everybody's house is um,
you know,
getting water damage.
They're in a panic and the charging thousands of dollars to go up there.
Can you imagine fucking doing that?
That fucking piece of shit.
People,
some old person who doesn't want to go up there or just in general,
if you've got some kids and stuff,
I mean,
you know,
you don't go up on the roof anyways if you've got a wife and kids,
right.
But the fucking,
you're not going up on a snowy roof in these fucking assholes.
A charging all that money.
I fucking hate when people do that.
Just start,
was it price gouging is not what they call it.
Shouldn't the president stepping right then?
That's what I do.
If I was president,
I would find out who the fuck was doing it and I would audit all of them.
Um,
all right.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody from Sunny California.
Oh yes.
Monday morning podcast.
And I'm,
I don't have shit to do today.
After I get this fucking podcast done.
I'm going to go play some drums.
I've got to tell you I did another one of those goddamn comedy jam.
So I'll tell you about after these messages about,
oh,
those glasses.
All right everybody.
I only got three this week.
It's the only to have to listen to me fucking read for a little bit.
Oh,
this is the favorite one.
Everybody.
Hey Bud.
Oh boat boat me undies beyond these.
No more sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
boop me undies.
Biondi you could wear him down at the mall or walk up to abroad with nice dry
nuts.
Get a fucking number and talk to some slots so you don't have no sweaty balls
when you were in fucking me undies.
All.
Yeah,
when you're wearing those me undies,
they were w may make up a women to no more sweaty clams.
We rarely made and no,
Bam,
sweaty
fucking bull poopy,
nice dry nuts.
Pow.
All right.
90%.
That's the,
that's the percent of your life that you're in your fucking underwear,
right?
Okay.
Unless you're Matthew mcconaughey or you're some fucking living in a slum in
India,
I'll never forget that.
Jesus Christ and underwear,
it gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on old saggy underwear.
[inaudible] your underwear,
quit your bowls,
quit when your balls quit you exceptional life.
You need,
uh,
you need to know the feeling of great fitting underwear that is two times softer
than cotton.
You need to know about me on these me,
mondays.com everybody,
me undies is the most comfortable underwear you will ever wear.
And it's insane how good they make you feel.
That's right.
You'll be walking around with half a Chubby.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you and they literally pull moisture gross away from your
skin so you can stay cool.
I have mine on right now and I'm floating.
Do I?
No,
I don't.
I got the old school one and you know what?
I knew there was something wrong with my balls.
They just didn't have that get up and go that they have with me undies.
Uh,
they have cool styles of both men and women and all.
They all look great.
Check out the photos yourself.
You see that twinkle in his eye?
That's cause his balls a nice and dry me undies.com this quality would typically
retail for two times the me undies price.
If you say so.
No retail men of middlemen means more savings for you.
Here,
I'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them or your first pair is free.
Okay?
All right.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
If you're thinking,
if you're thinking about starting a business,
now is the best time to do it.
It's national.
Start Your business month@legalzoom.com it's national business month,
like six months.
Start Your own business.
It's always national to start your own bed.
It's like one of those businesses that has gone out of business.
Everything must go when you see it for like three years.
All right?
Evidently it's national.
Start Your business month@legalzoom.com and it's never been easier to start
building your future.
Legal Zoom provides the support you need for more than 10 years.
Uh,
they've helped a million business owners just like you.
If you need advice for your business,
no problem,
dude.
You gotta do it.
You got to start your own business.
If you have an idea,
why wouldn't you do that?
You know what's great about having your own business?
You get to wake up when you want to wake up.
You don't have to wake up because someone else is telling you to wake up and
drag your ass into the Goddamn cubicle area,
right?
Legal Zone is not a lot from everybody,
but they built a network of trusted attorneys to provide the guidance you need
for your specific situation.
And here's the best pot.
During national starcher business month.
Legal Zoom is offering an attorney constellation for only 50 bucks.
Jesus Christ.
I just pictured that fucking lawyer.
Some old pair of loafers on.
Yeah.
Um,
if you're unsure about the best way to start or if you already run a business
and need some advice,
this offer is for you.
Get legal advice for your business with no obligation for a wall,
for a low one time cost.
Go to legalzoom.com today to find out more attorney consultations are provided
by independent attorneys available in most states.
That's hilarious.
If you can't get one your states,
you call it some southern lawyer,
right?
Like that Matlock guy og.
Oh,
dress locked the colonel Sanders.
What?
What do you want to start a new boy?
You want to make your own booth?
Uh,
get the legal help you need for your business@legalzoom.com and enter in Burton,
B U R R in the referral box to save even more legalzoom.com Promo code borough
legal help is here.
You know what?
I only have three.
Do you guys mind if I do one more and we'll do the classic one.
I'll read it like an auctioneer.
Aa,
but I don't know.
I don't want to stamp down calm.
I don't know how to do it.
Hey Buddy,
navigate tan.
We got to have a Canada I blah,
blah,
blah.
Actually have a school for learning how to do that.
Oh,
how bad would that be?
Especially the person that sucks and they don't have it.
And you just got to sit there watching the teacher just lose face and faith in
him.
You know,
I took an auctioneer in class,
you know,
they give you a little fucking diploma that you have get framed in.
Hang on your wall.
How sad is that?
Um,
stamps.com everybody,
you know that feeling you get when you get things done with just the click of
your mouse.
I can't get more convenient than that.
Oh,
I can think of a way I can.
It involves full.
Oh and now you can even get your mailing and shipping done without leaving your
desk.
Thanks to stamps.com stamps.com turns your PC or Mac into your own personal post
office that never closes.
Talk about convenient
lines from like the 1930s why audio?
Buy and official US postage for any letter or package using your computer and
printer.
Then just hand your mail to the mail man or mail way or drop it in a mailbox.
You'll never have to go to the post office again,
everybody.
You know what?
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters.
All right,
and if I can figure out how to use this,
so can you,
there's no way that you could be any dumber than I am right now.
Use My last name,
birth for this special offer.
I'm going to go low on this one.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale,
calculates the exact postage for letters and packages and up to $55 free
postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in bird.
That's stamps.com enter burr.
Dude,
I don't get those guys.
They always act like it's an amazing thing that they give you $110 in a digital
scale.
He,
if he'd do it all the fucking time,
it's not special anymore.
It's part of your offer.
And if you act now the same fucking thing we've been offering since the
beginning.
It's still on the table.
Um,
oh fuck.
What was I going to tell you guys about?
Oh,
speaking of that.
Posters.
Speaking of posters,
speaking of pollsters.
Oh,
Billy.
Red Space.
Guess what?
My southern tour.
I think tickets might even be on sale right now.
Oh,
I'm so fucking excited about this.
We're doing the bus tour.
We'll bring in the bus back the back of the buses back.
I don't know.
Um,
okay.
I got to think of,
I need you guys' help on this one because I need to come up with a name for the,
for the bus tour.
I'm going down to the south.
And,
uh,
and then also I also also,
I also,
yeah,
um,
mentioned that I was going to start possibly doing a,
I was gonna have a big announcement about,
I'm gonna start doing a podcast every random Thursday,
maybe like twice a month.
I don't know how I'm going to do this and I also need a name for that one.
MMM.
I have a hell of a time trying to come up with that shit.
I'm not good at that.
I'm going to run my fucking mouth.
All right.
Here we are.
I'm on bill burr shows.
All right,
here we go.
For those of you who are at your cubicle right now,
and you got to pretend that you're working and you're actually on a phone call,
I'll read you the dates that we got up here so far,
um,
that are on sale.
All right.
April 10th.
I'll be in Miami Beach,
Florida at the Fillmore,
Miami beach at the Jackie Gleason theater.
And I played this place before and I didn't go upstairs.
They have Jackie Gleason's office up there with a bunch of stuff that he had a
leftover,
you know,
that he would have morning he died.
They just kept it there.
It's a little shrine.
And I didn't know about that until after I left.
And I remember someone was like,
Hey,
did you go up and see it?
And I was like,
I was fucking pissed.
I didn't cause I used to love watching the honeymooners and I love the Jackie
Gleason show.
MMM.
Anyways,
April 11th I'll be in Tampa,
Florida at the Ruth.
Yeah.
Echo read hall.
Ruth Eckerd hall.
I don't know the fuck you say that.
Um,
for two shows.
April 11th.
All right.
And then the southern tour starts for some reason,
Miami,
I mean a Florida is not considered part of the south even though they were part
of the southern tour.
Last time we did a,
we did Tampa and then we went up to Tallahassee,
the Florida state,
I believe.
So anyways,
April 18th,
I'm going to be in Savannah,
Georgia.
Um,
April 19th,
Knoxville,
Tennessee.
It fucking kills me.
Then I'm going there and it's not football season.
That's on my bucket list to go to a Tennessee volunteer game,
man.
See that?
Purina cat chow and zone,
that checkerboard thing.
Watching everybody go one notch down there.
Having a sec.
Football mother fucker.
Chattanooga,
Tennessee.
April 20th,
Memphis,
Tennessee.
April 21st.
And I know what you thinking.
How come you didn't go to Nashville?
Because that's not what this tour's about.
Everybody goes to Tennessee,
goes to Nashville and then every cut in Tennessee who doesn't live there?
It's got to drive over to Nashville.
Guess what?
This sick of going to Nashville,
Knoxville,
Chattanooga and Memphis.
All right.
April 26.
I'll be in Huntsville,
Alabama.
All right.
April 27th,
Jackson,
Mississippi.
All right.
Um,
may
was it May 1st Evansville,
Indiana.
Well that's not the south.
Ah,
whatever.
We always got throw one wildcard in there.
Who the fuck goes to Evansville?
Nobody.
All right.
Um,
the,
just to let you know,
there's,
there's going to be some more dates in there.
Um,
we got some,
uh,
I think,
I think I got at least one other Mississippi date.
I'm so fucking excited about this.
I apps,
I have to tell you guys how much I love the fucking south.
Have I ever told you that?
Huh?
All the old cars you see the fucking people know how to fix up driving around
out there.
All the great barbecue,
all these fucking awesome places to eat.
The fucking music.
I absolute,
I fucking love it down there and I um,
I can't wait to go down there.
So anyways,
uh,
so the tickets are on sale.
Actually.
The Memphis,
Tennessee,
Huntsville,
Alabama and Jackson,
Mississippi,
those are not on sale yet.
But Evansville,
Chattanooga,
Knoxville,
Savannah,
Tampa and Miami beach are all on sale and a,
I might as well keep going here for people who aren't in the south.
Uh,
I'm playing the Wilbur and a Boston,
Massachusetts.
I'm doing a whole week.
I'm doing a week,
Ron Belper at the Wilbur.
Alright.
Tickets have been selling unbelievably.
Um,
we're,
we've sold 13 shows out,
if you can believe it.
And uh,
we're going to add a 14th and a,
that's all I'm gonna tell you that,
which is going to be a rough one,
you know?
Uh,
cause I'm going to be fucking seen a bunch of friends I love that's going to be
so fucking awesome.
Yeah.
That's what all comes down to.
It's all comes down to the fucking friends.
I see that I meet on the road and the fucking cigars.
I smoke,
although I've been keeping that in line this year.
Uh,
going easy on the cigars going EEG.
And the last date I have here,
June 26th and 27th,
um,
I'm going to be at the Mirage Casino and Las Vegas and my new hours coming
together.
I just did 92,
many stars and I was backstage going,
what do I do?
Do I do a couple of leftover bits?
Um,
do I do a couple of leftover bits from my last special that didn't make it or do
I go with some new shit?
And I just said,
fuck it.
I'm going with my new shit.
Fuck it.
I'm not doing another special for another year and a half.
Like I won't come up with another 10 minutes.
I know I can do that.
And uh,
I don't know.
That's my philosophy.
Fuck that.
You go hard,
come out with your best shit and just have faith that you're going to come up
with something else.
Um,
I hope I did the material justice.
It was a,
it was a really fun,
it was a really fun set.
And,
uh,
there was somebody famous in the crowd that was just fucking nothing,
just got nothing,
which always fucking kills you.
Like they're famous.
They know things,
you know.
But anyways,
so that I'm,
I'm really excited about that.
And uh,
like I said,
uh,
Jason Law,
Paul Versey,
I got the whole fucking crew coming around again.
Now we got coach coming out,
uh,
j law heads,
Hall of fame,
uh,
high school basketball coach.
Dad's coming along and uh,
we got it all worked out,
couldn't get the same bus driver,
which sucks.
He's,
uh,
I dunno,
I think we thought what was going to be in May at first,
but now it's going to be in April and he's driving a band,
def Leppard actually through Canada,
so he can't be there.
But that stinks.
So we'll get him next time.
But he recommended somebody that hopefully we're going to get,
we'll have a good time,
blah,
and all that bullshit.
So,
um,
I need a name for the tour.
I'd love to hear your suggestions and um,
let me see what else.
You know what the easiest way to do it?
Just send it to the,
um,
which I don't fucking have of course,
because I'm a dumb fuck.
Oh,
this,
this podcast.
You know what?
This was a good podcast right up til the light.
It just did.
The whole fucking thing just went off the rails.
How dumb is it that I don't even know?
I don't even know what the Twitter handle is for my own fucking podcast.
He realized how fucking not even sad at this point.
Don't,
don't you guys?
Yeah.
Built.
We expect that out of you.
We expect that lack of professionalism at the m m
okay.
Podcast.
Is that what it is?
What is it?
Oh,
go fuck yourself,
Bill.
You,
you suck.
You just fucking suck.
I'm the worst.
I don't even know what it is.
Somebody find it and then fucking tweet me it so I know what my own God.
Damn,
I can't even find the thing.
I follow it.
It should be coming up.
Okay.
Is it at the M and podcast?
I'm sorry you guys have to listen to this.
There it is.
I got it.
All right,
so at the m m podcast,
um,
if you could just tweet me your ideas for the name of the southern tour and um,
I already know some of you are going to be a little wacky with your ideas
slapping on the knee there,
um,
for that or the Thursday podcast.
Um,
even if I don't use what you have,
I'll,
there will be a nice jump off point for me and I'm,
I can actually come up with something.
I'm going to come up with a real cool tour poster.
I'm going to sign all of the posters and a,
I'll be out there during the southern tour.
Uh,
you know,
shaking hands,
kissing babies and all that shit.
And,
uh,
all I ask you guys,
you just tell us where to go get some drinks and where the cool places are to
eat.
Um,
and we do not want to go to any chains.
We want to go to the fucking spot.
And if the spot is the shit,
the local mom and pop places to shit,
I promise you I will not tell anybody about it because you know,
as much as the food network and all of them,
you know,
they have their heart in the right fucking place.
Uh,
you know,
they end up blowing up the place and then every dose like me comes to town,
with my fucking flip flops and a brochure and then you can't get a seat there
anymore.
So I won't do it.
I won't do that to you.
But uh,
if you could let us know,
that would be fucking tremendous.
Um,
so anyways,
I just mentioned that I'm trying to keep my cigar smoking.
I'm trying to get it under control and it's actually scary how many I've already
smoked this year to actually count them.
I smoked 13 so far.
And uh,
that is a lot.
So I'm thinking last year where I didn't even pay attention,
I easily smoked over a hundred fucking sick guys.
I must have every three,
four days,
I would think.
So sometimes I go,
you know,
and then,
sometimes they go like 10,
12 days,
but then I go on like a three day run,
but I was hanging with versa or something like that.
And uh,
I know it's bad.
I know I got to stop and there was a,
you know,
Leonard Nimoy passing away,
his last fucking tweet is,
uh,
don't smoke.
I wish I didn't.
Something like that.
Live long and prosper and uh,
you know,
the guy was like fucking 83,
84 years old.
And even then if you're laying on your deed,
think,
you know,
as a young person,
he'd be like,
Oh man,
that's a great run.
I'd love to fucking live that long.
But when you fucking facing it at 83 84 and it's still too early,
you know what I mean?
I just think if,
if you die because of your lifestyle,
I think that's a tough one to get over when you lie in there.
You know,
it's one thing if you just,
you know,
something tragic happens and that that's not yours.
But if you are actually shoveling something India fucking mouth that caused you
to die earlier and spend less days on earth,
I mean,
that's gotta be a motherfucker.
And just the fact that the guy 84 still had a little bit of regret about that.
That was really an eye opener.
So I was trying to do one cigar week this year,
which is still 52 fucking cigars.
Right?
That's fucking ridiculous.
That's still unacceptable.
So anyways,
so right now we're about nine weeks in.
I should be on cigar number nine and I'm already up to 13 should be all the way
into April.
So I'm actually going to take this month off.
I'm not going to smoke any,
although a buddy of mine's coming to town Friday and they already said we're
going to smoke.
Well,
maybe you have to number 14 oh Geez.
That's a rough one,
you know?
MMM.
Anyways,
I got to get this thing under control.
I'm really good at like,
I don't have any cigars in my house anymore.
Uh,
the,
the fucking human door is shut down.
Yeah.
Whatever the fuck he call humidifier.
Oh,
that's for fucking singers.
Humidors for fucking gap.
There you go.
Yeah.
That's shut down.
I'm not fucking using that thing anymore.
And uh,
I've been booze and way less you once in a while.
I got to shut it down.
But uh,
anyways,
let me talk about the goddamn comedy jam,
everybody.
So last week I had,
for the fourth time I did it.
This is my favorite fucking show to do.
And uh,
this time we did a guns and roses paradise city.
I dressed up like Steven Adler,
one of my favorite drummers of all time.
And uh,
it was really cool.
I watched a bunch of old guns and roses videos just to see how,
what he dressed like and just watch how he played,
uh,
to do maybe a mini impression of him,
which I don't think I did.
I,
cause I'm,
I'm not comfortable enough playing in front of them.
Uh,
Pat Club.
Yeah,
playing live like this point to actually throw in a little bit of an
impersonation of the drummer.
I'll,
I'll get to that level of comfort,
comfort because that's what I'm working on each time.
Each time I play a little bit better,
but I'm still at the point of like,
oh my God,
don't fuck this song up.
Um,
which I always do,
but uh,
this is what was the best that I played.
And I'm not gonna lie to you,
man for a bunch of comedians.
We fucking killed it for a professional band.
I Dunno.
But,
uh,
it was so much fucking fun.
And,
um,
I think I tweeted a couple of pictures of me dressed to Steven Adler,
you know,
it's fucking hilarious though,
was uh,
he wore like a lot of like tank tops and shit like that,
which I wasn't going to wear.
I'm too fucking self conscious about my pasty torso.
So,
uh,
he wore some vests and shit like that,
so I just had a white t shirt and I bought like this leather vest and a,
with the wig and the sunglasses.
It looked funny.
Right.
But I gotta tell you at one point,
you know,
I was at home by myself and I had the t shirt on.
I had on the leather vest and I put the sunglasses on it.
And before it,
before I put the wig on,
I looked in the mirror and I looked like rob hello.
You know,
not to say he doesn't look good in a vest.
I'm just saying I shouldn't shit on him.
Um,
yeah.
I,
I cannot pull off a fucking leather vest.
That is,
that is a spa you need,
you need hair to pull that off.
All right.
If you don't,
you just,
I can't even tell you what I fucking look like.
I look like somebody output.
Chino would have talked to and cruising back in back in the day in that fucking
movie.
Um,
I would have bursted out if it wasn't so shocking.
How fucking silly I looked.
Um,
oh yeah,
it was bad.
It was bad.
But anyways,
I put the fucking wig on,
which was actually a woman's wig,
you know,
it's hard to find is a fucking heavy metal,
long blonde wig.
They just didn't have them,
was all black hair,
brown hair.
And then they had a one that was actually the right consistency,
but it was his whitish kind of hair looks stupid.
So I had to fucking comb the thing down.
I looked fucking ridiculous.
And everyone like,
you know,
it was funny was when I came walking out,
uh,
the drummer in the band,
nick,
who plays Bass when I sit in,
he never,
he when he gets to see like,
well,
however I'm dressing up is as I walk out on stage and I saw him,
that's the hardest.
I saw him laughing.
So I knew it was a,
uh,
it was a good thing.
So then I just went up and I did a set and I basically was defending and add
Steven Adler saying that he shouldn't have been kicked out of guns and roses and
I knew all this nerdy shit about him.
So,
uh,
the crowd really enjoyed it and all the while I was reading his autobiography
and I got as much as I love
Steven Adler,
I got to tell you when I read the fucking,
the book,
there was that fucking junky thing where he was not taking response.
That's like not once in the book did he say like,
all right,
I'm going to admit on this day or on this Gig,
I was too fucked up to play and I played really sloppy.
It was just,
he always had some sort of a fucking reason.
But what I liked about the book was because I read slashes book and I still felt
like he was trying not to piss off axle because the chance of a reunion was
still there.
And Axel,
so fucking I guess touchy or whatever.
What I did like about Adler's was he didn't give a shit and it seemed like he
didn't give a fuck either.
When he was in the band,
he had this great story of one night they went out to play,
they went out to play live and uh,
acts,
it goes out to sing and the monitors were fucked up and he was just like,
fuck this show and walked off stage after two or three songs.
And as he was walking by Adler,
he gave him shit and was like,
well axle maybe if you showed up for the fucking soundcheck,
things would sound right,
you know,
actually said.
Then I,
whenever I,
whenever I see shit,
whenever I read stuff about that band,
cause I fucking love that band.
It was just like,
I don't know,
it's just awful watching how everybody just fucking let that guy spin out it.
At least it seems that way,
right?
You're like how I've read so many of those books actually think I know what
happened in the band.
I'm going to shut up now.
I sound like a total nerd.
But anyways.
Um,
is there anything else I wanted to talk about this week before I get into your
questions?
Uh,
my momentarily mentioned that,
uh,
the Bruins are starting to play better.
Thank God I mentioned native too many stars.
Uh,
what else?
What else?
I think that's it.
Um,
all right,
let's get into,
let's get into the,
uh,
the old questions here for the week.
All right,
drummer.
You know,
I've seen this before.
Somebody sent this to me and said,
hey,
bill,
this article has been going around all week.
I'm sure someone sent it to you.
It's about how drummers are more intelligent.
How's it feel to be the exception?
Uh,
he says,
just kidding.
Go Fuck Yourself.
So obviously he's shitting on me.
So there's this new study that claims that drummers are actually more
intelligent than everyone.
So right there,
that's fucking ridiculous.
That's not true.
But it's basically,
it says that,
uh,
because,
well,
let me just read this thing.
Um,
according to a collection of studies,
drummers are super smart dude.
A variety of factors relating to being in the rhythm section.
So would that mean like the bass player and the rhythm guitarist or were the
piano player,
whatever fucking you makes up your rhythm section would all be smarter.
Okay.
I Dunno,
the news comes courtesy of Pauli.
Mick does it gives it to the fact that I can't even spell up.
I can't really say I'm a drama.
It's just a hobby.
Um,
who have compiled a series of reports from Oxford and Harvard.
Ooh,
universities.
So name a few.
What they found was that the dude at the back of the band isn't the head
scratcher that you might think he is.
In fact,
he's more likely to be the smartest of the mall.
For examples,
researchers at Stockholm's Karolinska Institute found that the drummers who kept
a tighter rhythm also scored better on 60 question,
uh,
intelligent test.
This is a reflection of better problem solving skills,
which creates a positive impact on those around them.
Or they just a smart person who decided to play drums.
So naturally they would score higher.
I don't know that I buy into that.
I think that that's a,
uh,
it's,
I think this article is a reaction to all the,
the,
the drummer jokes.
Um,
you know,
for those usual that aren't in play music or whatever musician on as I guess is
what you'd fucking call it.
That was,
you play music.
Hey,
for those of you play music,
um,
there's a brunch,
a drummer jokes like,
uh,
what do you call somebody who hangs around musicians,
a drummer,
you know,
um,
how do you know there's a drummer at the door than knocking speeds up?
I guess that's one of,
we're talking about our timing or whatever,
but like,
it's,
there's a lot in like drummers that are fucking morons who just bash shit in
there.
They're not actually musicians.
So I think that this is a reaction to that to say
[inaudible] lead singer,
really good
tourists.
You know,
I think that that's just what this is.
So do I buy into it?
No,
I don't.
I don't,
I think that there's,
um,
you know,
I think that there's super smart people that decide,
okay,
that are whatever,
get into music.
Some of them are drummers,
some of them play the fucking oboe.
But I don't think,
uh,
I gotta admit,
you know,
I've met a ton of drummers and it's just like meeting people.
Some are cool.
So assholes,
some of smart,
you know,
I think it's just a,
yeah,
I don't buy
into it.
All right.
Whatever.
There we go.
All right.
How to not wreck your eyes.
Okay,
Bill,
you are 100% correct.
Finally,
if your eyes are trying to adjust for flicker,
it wears out.
Where's the amount?
Big Time.
Well it sounds very medical.
Um,
for this reason you never need,
you never read or study under a single fluorescent bulb.
A buddy of mine lost his pilot qualification this way with only one fluorescent
bulb.
Your eyeball kills itself trying to dilate and constrict and an impossible
speed.
Oh yeah.
Cause it Kinda like flickers cause I don't understand fluorescent bulbs.
And I also don't understand why whenever I go to home depot I accidentally buy
those every fucking time.
I look all over the box.
I can't seem to find where it says fluorescent anyways.
Oh,
what,
what does a regular light called?
It's not fluorescent.
What's the good one?
The nice warm one that makes my eyes go right.
Ah,
I can see.
What does it make your eyes bill do bill.
Ah,
okay.
Anyways,
my,
uh,
my buddy's eye doctor told,
told him that if would have to study under fluorescent,
make sure it's at least two bulbs.
All you'll wreck your eyes.
Uh,
as he did his hope.
This helps.
Well,
you know what can help if somebody helped me fucking read that God damn thing.
Um,
all right,
franchise.
This is hilarious.
I'm finally allowing enough time to get through all the goddamn reads and now I
have nothing to say about any of them.
Alright.
Franchise Bill.
Not sure if anyone asks you.
Uh,
not sure if anyone's asked you think before.
Once again,
people not proofreading.
I already have a difficult time reading out loud bill.
Not sure if anyone's asked you what you think before,
but if you could own a current sports franchise,
which would it be?
Or if you had to create a franchise for any sport in any city,
which would you pick?
What would you call the team?
What city could really use a team in particular in a particular sport?
Thanks.
Um,
all right,
let's see here.
So I think somebody asked me this before,
all right.
If I could,
hmm.
If I could own any sports team,
I'm like most sports fans,
I would want to own a sports team from the city that I'm from in back in the day
when I was growing up,
I would then go to be the greatest owner of all time.
And not only would we win a championship,
we would win the most championships of in the sport.
And during the time that I own the team,
you know,
um,
but unfortunately that dream has died for me because not only do I have the
money,
but every Boston team has gone out and won championships and uh,
you know,
so I,
I can't really,
I,
am I going to be a better owner than Robert Craft?
No,
the people over at the Red Sox,
right.
The Bruins,
the Celtic I,
you know,
what am I going to do?
I guess right now the team that I'm most concerned about will probably be the
Boston Celtics and I would want them to win a bunch of championships so they
stay out in front of the Lakers.
Um,
cause the Lakers have,
you know,
they've just won so many goddamn championships since the 70s.
It's insane.
And of course they count that one from the,
the,
the Ba or whatever the fuck it is,
which is so fucking ridiculous.
But such a classic La thing.
I actually think it's funny that they do it because everybody out his pad and
their resume,
you know,
no one's a fucking waitress.
They're all an actress.
Everybody's a director and that type of shit.
Sorry.
You want to see,
you got,
you got 16.
We won an NBA championship before there was an NBA.
Oh,
did you?
How'd you do that?
Because we're in La.
Um,
so maybe that one I think,
but um,
I think,
um,
if I had to own any team,
I would,
it would probably be,
be a team in a city that I love,
a team that was probably great when I was a kid.
But isn't any more,
I would maybe a the turn the Pittsburgh pirates around or the Baltimore Orioles
even though they had a great year last year.
Um,
let me see.
That's a damn good question.
Okay.
It's a damn good question.
I think,
uh,
I don't know.
There's so many fucking teams.
I hate after awhile if you watch enough sports,
you fucking hate all of them.
You just like you a team,
let's say just stink every God damn year.
I Dunno,
you know,
back in the day I was thinking like a owning a Canadian hockey team cause they
haven't had the cup there and so long it'd be cool to bring it back.
Obviously it wouldn't be the Canadians and maple leaf fans are such fucking shit
talking [inaudible] I wouldn't want them to see any success either.
And I gotta be honest with you.
We always lose to them and the gold medal game in the Olympics and then they'd
talk all this fucking shit.
You know what?
Fuck all those teams,
fuck them all.
But if I had to pick one,
uh,
maybe I bring Edmonton Back Calgary.
I like there was a time,
believe it or not,
that I actually used to like Vancouver before we played them in the finals and
then I fucking hate and but enough of them have left that,
I think they have a new personality,
but they still have the [inaudible] twins there.
Um,
who I don't even know what,
why would I not like them?
What?
Cause they're good,
I dunno.
Yeah.
I think I would just be a hometown thing or like the Pittsburgh pirates or
something like that or maybe bring a championship to Cleveland,
I think would be great to make the browns.
Yeah.
Maybe I'd take the browns.
Yeah,
I make the Browns,
but I would tell people to stop fucking eating dog biscuits in that type of
shit.
That would be,
that would be the trade off.
You have to come to the game dress like a human being.
You don't go there and humiliate yourself.
Gold boom,
boom,
boom.
Thinking you're actually affecting the defense of the other team.
Like,
oh my God,
fuck this 360 pound tackle that's going to be pulling that I have to fucking get
crushed by to force the run back to the inside.
Fuck all that.
There's a fan account and eaten a dog biscuit barking at me that's really
messing with my focus man.
Um,
or you know,
maybe bring a football team to la,
but you know something.
I don't think they deserve it.
All right.
Fucking southern California fans.
All we have to San Francisco and Oakland,
they're fucking horrific.
Not all of them,
but just that they're a horrible fucking people who bring violence to the game
and they,
they beat up people who wear different uniforms.
I mean just,
I mean somebody gets shot at like a fucking 40 niners Raiders like preseason
game.
And what those fucking assholes at the dodger game did.
Did that family,
that father with a family where they had a couple of kids at guys,
he's brain dead.
Basically.
It's got permanent brain damage.
He took the,
they took this,
these kids dad away.
What does kids right there?
There's no excuse.
You saw that he was a father,
so fuck all of them.
They don't deserve a fucking team.
There you go.
Um,
that answers,
that answers your question.
All right.
Name change or not?
This is a crazy one.
Hey,
yo,
belly.
I have heard you talk about isis a few times on the Monday morning podcast,
so I thought I'd ask your opinion on something that's been bothering me for a
while now.
My husband and I had our child in the fall of 2013 throughout my pregnancy.
We spent a lot of time trying to come up with the perfect name and tried to make
sure it was a name that no one could make fun of.
Okay,
and why don't you just go with Susan?
Yeah.
Kathy,
Karen,
all the classics.
No one's going to give you shit about those.
After months and months of debate,
we finally settled on the name Isis after the Bob Dylan Song.
Yeah.
I don't understand what happens to two parents between being a child and being
picked on and bullied and all that type.
There's just something about it.
When you become a parent,
you just forget and you buy your kids stupid clothes.
Please beat the shit out of me clothes.
And then you give your kid a name like Isis.
Let's just say Isis.
The terrorist group didn't exist.
All right.
Isn't that Lego?
That's I guess when I was a kid,
isis was,
I got to look this up.
That was like a,
there was some superhero that was a woman.
All Mighty Isis.
Isis.
Isis,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
because people who like named their kid like Thor.
All right.
Isis woman.
It's my search.
Okay.
Hero.
This is going to put me on an FBI fucking watch list because Isis and heroin and
the same thing.
Yeah.
MMM.
Images for Isis.
Woman Hero.
Isis TV series 75 76.
I remember that.
She go all mighty isis.
Isis,
Isis.
And then she,
it was like,
it was a rip off a wonder woman.
Isis.
DC comics.
Here we go.
Um,
here we go.
My slow ass Internet.
Hey,
we go.
Isis is a DC comics superhero.
God Damn,
look at her.
Holy Shit.
I swear to God,
man.
There's any woman look better than a woman that a guy draws.
Um,
all right.
Isis is a DC comic superhero as well as a separate Egyptian goddess also living
in the DC universe.
The recent superhero character is modeled closely after the main character of
the secrets of Isis,
a live action American Saturday morning television program that served as the
second half of Shizam.
I remember that.
Okay.
Shizam Isis hour,
the television character appeared in the late seventies DC comic publication.
Yeah,
I remember this shit.
So that to me that,
that,
that's what it was.
Um,
all right.
Let me go back to your question here.
So a well as you know,
a few months ago after a few months after she was born,
this stupid terrorist group who just so happens to go by the name Isis is all
over the news.
Isis is actually a beautiful name.
I shouldn't be making fun of it.
Um,
I don't know all of the political aspects of the group and I really don't care.
All I know is that a year later these people are still all over the news and
don't seem to be going away anytime soon.
I don't know.
These terrorist groups,
it kind of like boy bands,
you know what I mean?
They're fucking hot for a couple of summers and then they just kind of go away,
you know?
Like,
um,
okay.
But like,
like Hezbollah is like fucking the backstreet boys at this point,
you know,
in Isis is like a,
not the Jonas brothers,
Jonas brothers like Hezbollah,
right?
Oh,
the al Qaeda.
I'd say they're more like the al Qaeda and Isis is like a,
isis was the,
wherever the f those fucking people are.
Whoever the new one is.
Right.
That's who they are.
Okay.
All I know is that a year later these people are still all over the news and
don't seem to be going anywhere anytime soon.
We tried ignoring it,
but every time we have to tell someone our daughter's name,
we either get a weird confused look.
Oh,
we get someone who tells us she should start going by her middle name.
Wow.
Okay.
Who'd say that to a mother?
We have thought about,
I guess I'm old enough that when I,
when I heard Isis,
when I heard that,
well just to let you know,
when I heard Isis,
the terrorist group,
I laughed at the name cause I was thinking like that's that superhero that was a
rip off a wonder woman.
You know what I mean?
Anyways,
we have thought about having her go by her middle name until all this blows over
but she just doesn't look like anything than an isis to us.
So we decided that would be too weird.
One solution we have thought of is to change your name to something that is
similar to isis so she can still use the nicknames shortened version of our
current name,
but we won't have the word Isis tied to her legally.
So my question is this,
do we have,
do we let everyone else win?
I'll go through all of the legal and financial burdens of getting her name
change or do we keep her name as it is now continued to put up with all the side
comics and dirty looks and help.
Who would think that someone would name a little girl.
Okay.
After a terrorist group,
what state do you live in and hope the terrorist group,
Isis doesn't turn out into any bigger deal than it already is.
Thanks to the advice and as always go fuck yourself.
Um,
I say you stand strong at this point.
That's what I say.
I say you stay with the name.
It's actually a beautiful name.
That's a beautiful name for a little girl.
Isis is a beautiful name.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you.
You know,
cause then it's like,
all right,
so we are going to be stubborn and then
yeah,
I will show you what a fucking situation,
cause then it's like
your kid's going to be young enough.
They'd be switch it.
Now it's not going to remember,
but if you go too long,
that would be weird.
If all of a sudden somebody changed my name to like chuck.
Hey Charlie.
Charlie.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
This my name.
Hey,
how are you?
What's going on here?
That'd be weird.
Um,
yeah,
that's sucks.
That's sucks.
And it also sucks that they're making isis out to be this huge fucking deal.
You know what I mean?
That we're focusing all these billions of dollars on this little ass fucking
group,
right?
And meanwhile,
over here,
you know,
you have people that took,
took control of the food supply.
And from what I've read,
if essentially turned it into poison,
isn't that terrorist behavior right here?
He can't focus on that.
You can't focus on bankers and all these fucking concept about that shit.
I swear to God,
I don't understand why we can't just fucking build shit in this country,
fix our own fucking shit.
It look,
you know,
electric cars,
the batteries and shit that they're gonna do.
Just as much damage to the environment is oil and gas are,
you know,
they are.
But here's the deal,
if we do,
if we fucking switch over to that shit
and then we don't use oil,
they fucking go bankrupt.
And if they go bankrupt,
all these cons that are literally on our side can't fund the money into these
terrorist groups and then they fucking go away.
Right?
And then you can have a kid named Emma,
you know,
Hezbollah
as he batting next,
Hezbollah Saunders his ball or soccer.
Um,
alright.
Yeah.
So I don't know.
That's,
that's,
that's sucks.
I actually,
you know something I Kinda gave you shit in the beginning.
I actually feel really bad for you.
Um,
because you love your kid.
You love the name,
then that's all one thing.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't think isis is going to be around too long.
I just think that they're a,
the two desperate,
you know what I mean?
The two desperate for attention,
just the shit that they're doing,
they're really kind of Hacky,
cutting people's heads off light and people on fire.
It's always some sensational fucking thing.
You know what I mean?
Like if they were a comedian,
they would just be,
they'd have a catch phrase,
I feel like.
Oh,
they did.
They'd wear the same clothes every time they went on stage and the fucking,
you know,
they did try and too hard to be evil.
I feel that they think they're actually going to,
they're going to last.
They fucking allegedly a man who knows once it goes through all the fucking
propaganda on all this shit,
that person they threw off the roof was allegedly a gay guy and they were thrown
off because he was getting just like fucking animals.
I just don't think they're going to lie.
I think he,
I think even they are too fucking insane to last is what I'm hoping.
Okay.
You know,
and um,
I dunno,
that's a rough one because I think my whole life,
I will remember the name has Bulla,
I will remember the name Al Qaeda.
Will I remember Isis though.
I,
you know there's a big boy band out right now.
I don't know the name of it.
Oh Man.
That's a motherfucker.
I don't know.
I don't know what to tell you.
You know what?
I might have to phone a friend.
What do you guys think?
Let's take a vote.
All right.
You got three things.
Come up with a name for my southern tour.
Helped me come up with a name for my southern tour.
Should say,
help me come up with a name for the Thursday podcast.
Um,
the Thursday,
Monday morning podcast.
Um,
and to help this woman make this decision.
Ah,
that's fucking blows.
Imagine if you had a kid,
you just named them Eddie,
some regular name and then there's some new terrorist group over there and Eddie
somehow stood for something,
you know,
eviction of,
fucking know in the Lopers except it worked with Eddie
anyways.
Um,
any way shit.
Anyways,
uh,
so that's a podcast for this week.
Everybody came out right in about an hour this week.
I'm psyched that my Bruins is starting to play.
Well again,
you don't try to stay ahead of the fucking path is
mmm,
I'm really a,
I don't know what to tell you.
I'm actually thinking about that sports question again.
I would like to start an upstart league,
an upstart basketball league.
There's just too many fucking teams already.
I would like to do that and bring a team back,
have bring back like the Rochester royals,
you know,
that'd be fun.
You know,
something actually thinking about that now that rethink this question.
Um,
seeing how fucking awesome the fans are.
When I went to a Oklahoma thunder game,
is that right?
Is it the thunder?
I can't even remember some sort of weather.
I don't watch hope.
Wow.
My brain is fried.
Um,
yeah.
Oklahoma City Thunder.
Yeah.
Just seeing how fucking awesome their fans were and just the stadium that they
built,
which was just bare bones.
Nothing crazy like the staple center in some of these other places.
And the place was so fucking loud because,
uh,
you don't have all that wasted space of luxury boxes and everything.
So it's really contained and it's like super loud.
Um,
I think it would be fun to,
uh,
bring a professional team to a place like Rochester or something like that.
I think that it would be really bad ass now that I rethink it.
And A,
I'm psycho into fucking college hoops right now.
Um,
and I actually kills me when I was in New York.
I didn't,
I,
I last second.
I looked up to see when Saint John's was playing in the game was already going.
It was down at Madison Square Garden.
Then it could have fucking gone.
A fucking bugs me anyways.
All right.
I'm,
I'm okay.
My came in like a lion and went out like a lamb,
by the way.
March 2nd.
This is my 23rd anniversary as being a standup comedian.
Live in the dream coming up on a quarter century.
What am I going to buy myself for my 25th anniversary?
Um,
all right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
Um,
I hope it doesn't keep snowing back east even though it makes me laugh,
but,
uh,
that is it.
I will talk to you guys soon.
Uh,
rest in peace,
Leonard Nimoy.
Um,
and thanks for the advice on smoking.
I will try to fucking quit a little bit.
You know,
G G C..